Failing was the best thing that ever happened to me for,
I think for everybody failed.
Not because some people get stuck at their failure and they become bitter and
they become envious.
They become hateful,
at least how to mock they.
They can.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But failure can be one of the best things that ever happened to failing and
having to learn to become a business person.
I'm very thankful for removed from the failure.
Now don't you think that about your rap career as well?
Like that's what I saw.
Oh,
from business perspective as well.
From [inaudible] at rat first,
not,
I was a good rapper,
but outcast Tacoma and I records my,
my,
my first record went gold at a time where we read the record was going 10
million.
It was a fee.
It didn't work.
Right.
It didn't work for me.
So I had to go to Texas and people like chameleon,
Aaron Paul Wall,
um,
Bun B,
zero slim thug Trae to truth,
right?
People like flip and hump.
These people taught me how to press up my own cds,
put them in the marketplace,
sell them at profit,
reinvest themselves.
They taught me that and selling drugs,
you know,
in a drought.
They taught me to rudimentary fundamentals of business and when I met my wife,
I can remember date and two,
three,
four or five little hot chicks and her just mentally being,
you know,
my wife caught her,
right.
Right.
Freshman Year of college.
But just mentally she was light years ahead of everyone because the grandmother
had raised her in that way.
Grandmother had a shot house.
Right.
You know,
I ran a sh or like a Chitlin circuit.
You Go,
got to get a shot for $2 on Sundays because the south has,
you know,
it's a weird place we didn't use to sell how call on Sunday.
So my wife,
I recognize how to sharper mind and me for business.
What I had was good ideas for what would sale or what would be well in the
marketplace and what she had was a discipline to Oregon.
Have any failures in your business practice or jam?
At first few years,
I had a barber shop.
I wanted to kill every Barbara barbers are like independent rappers,
you know,
everyone wants to be more famous than they need to be.
An artist.
Barbers want to be famous.
Yeah.
Barbara's life via famous.
I mean there are local,
yeah,
the artists.
Absolutely.
And they should be,
you know what I mean?
But um,
with the essay,
it,
man,
it just frustrating,
you know,
when Barbara comes in one day like I want to wear a glitter Cape today.
The next part was coming and like,
yeah,
I want,
if I want to cut hair in the nude,
I don't want to use your shot to do it.
And you're like,
Bro,
it doesn't,
it doesn't work like that.
Like this is the right.
But I had to learn for us that the booth rent model,
like you pay in booth renting us not making any more profit that doesn't knit.
So we had to kind of say,
well,
what is super cuts do?
What does great clips too?
Oh,
you wanted it by commission and then you split.
That means they have to beat it.
And no way.
And that's how we kinda learned business.
When we got an offer from the hawks to put our place in the space of the arena
and we want to be a more arenas,
we started to understand,
okay,
this is how you do business business.
You know,
this is not just how you,
you know,
make two to $4,000 extra a month and that's just some good income for your wife
to be able to enjoy it.
But this is how you start to say,
you know,
more than the bright barbershop.
This is a lifestyle and retail brand and we happened to Barbara.
But if you're a guy,
I don't like going to the beauty shops or beauty,
um,
stores to buy my brushes or by my combs or you know,
if you want to get a little gray out,
if your beard,
you know,
you don't want to be in the RAF section of your local Walmart or you're like,
hey,
where do I get the grade for my beer?
Cause I want to go get hot young chicks.
You know,
you want to go into a shop.
And so we develop products,
we have cool stuff.
You can just buy it right there.
And we've learning to be business people and hopefully I would like to become
the chick filet of barber shops.
I like for people to want to want to have us in their town and pay us a lot of
money to come.
Well it's a man's hangout too.
And then you can say anything you want and no one judges,
you can tall,
you can watch the Joe Rogan Talk Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Barbershops are uniquely masculine.
They are like beauty shops are for girls.
Girls can go into a beauty shop and get their nails done and no,
there's not going to be any man there.
They can talk all kinds of crazy shit.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why they like it.
Yep.
And,
and the women that do come to barbershops are some of the best shit talkers.
So even they fit in.